what is up everybody
good afternoon and welcome back to
GameSpot live Persia here and today we
are checking out the Lawrence I did get
a chance to play a couple matches it's
gonna be a doozy hahaha
as you guys know probably from past Rams
I'm definitely controller player but
we're playing on keyboard today we're
gonna make the best of it this game that
has been pretty interesting pretty fun
but you know getting used to the
shooting style if you play Counter
Strike at all it's very similar to that
and after playing so many crazy shooters
like apex and stuff I'm gonna have to
get used to it so let's see how it goes
I know there's a lot of really good
people playing this game already but I'm
excited because it's something kind of
new and kind of old it does so very
familiar obviously it's got abilities it
kind of like overwatch but there's a lot
of abilities and you can buy a few you
start out with a few you have your
ultimate it's pack there's a lot of
stuff going on so thank you guys so much
for joining I hope you are having a
great day and a let's shoot some folks
alright um I'm just gonna go ahead and
start we're just gonna do some what I
need to make sure I'm not in custom
still because I did go to like a
practice game to try out some of the
guns didn't get this notification last
time but let's see
yeah I do feel like this is way more oh
wait this is a custom we I knew it I
knew it I was like something's weird
crap how do I get out I'm still also
navigating I might have to go back in
take it out still navigating it's a
little crazy but yeah hello Ryan and
breathtaking and epically noob and
Brandon of course Tony is back in town I
promise
alright so it's pretty cool I've kind of
been using Silva only recently only
because some of the other characters I
want to try actually everyone gets to
them first so there we go
but yeah how are you guys doing hey much
love to all of you guys as well thanks
for the support as always we're at home
still like much like everyone else's
right now but it's all good we're here
to play ooh
all right yeah so I'll start with Silva
but I'll try to hop around to as many
other characters as I can I still have
four that I need to unlock you can
unlock them as you play though so the
first character I unlocked was actually
cypher I had all the other ones already
but we'll start with him he is Hanzo
esque
like he has an arrow you can shoot that
reveals people in a certain area you can
also select how many times it bounces
off a wall so if you're not really in an
angle to shoot it directly like someone
you can use a little bit of geometry
bounce it off the walls and try to you
know find a good angle he has like a
recon drone kind of like Krypto from
apex oh he can summon summon it it
doesn't have a very long shelf life I
could be using it wrong also but it
doesn't go very far but you can like tag
somebody with a with a dart that
playbook at us so I'm Sarah before
he's very much a recon character so
here's the drone you buy your abilities
down here as you start to get money I
could buy them right now but I think I'm
gonna kind of save up a little bit and
you know it's the first round so okay
cool still learning the maps also but I
I think I did manage to play at least
one game on all of the maps they have
little zip lines you can use yeah
[Music]
obviously everything makes a lot of
noise so you can walk slowly to reduce
some noise or you can Crouch walk to
reduce the noise see I see somebody but
there's this or appear so rest in peace
teammates it looks more adult than
overwatch it's definitely no so more
about being very strategic right as I
filled with overwatch you can can use
mobility and a lot of characters have
passives to help with stuff like that
so so yeah I need all the shields I can
get I don't really want either the ropes
but we need some help other abilities
too so you guys can check that out
the max seemed pretty big just because
of the fact that feeling happy when you
map up on the top left
did I not buy that gun and I also have
this drone so long finding out take a
peek see if I see anyone over here if
someone was there I would have given me
the option to shoot them with a dino we
just died he just killed the bomb
carrier the spike carrier excuse me
revealing area 30 seconds left
found them aha
oh my god
spike planted last player standing
I heard that me I heard it I heard that
seem to you from my face it's broken
from the first person that died from me
let me buy again course is mine this
time no shields ouch it's probably not
smart all right
I still have one check you can buy two
of the cubes if I still have one so
let's go
the feet are so loud it makes me really
nervous about walking around
I have to really force myself to not
strafe when I'm shooting also because
one enemy remaining in on me down I'll
get right back up my drone so the
ultimate ability though you need to
actually do stuff like it kills that's
up to you use it it's not something that
charges overtime right it's like high
heels my my feet they're so loud
dealing that word blasts I know you can
ping areas but they didn't really push
out of their base much that rounds this
will be a very competitive game
obviously yeah I think so I think that
you sports for this game is gonna be
wild the twitch rivals tournament
already happened and it was pretty cool
everyone's already already making it
very interesting to watch even the
highlights from that's remember really
revealing area looks like the other
twice going the same way I tried to
switch it up a little bit one enemy
remaining and just bodies everywhere
there's only one person left be the area
found them we're standing destroyed me I
got oh this is the other cool thing
actually about this game on the bright
side Oh ding the cameras in the way
alright he got her but let me move this
camera it tells you like exactly where
you landed your shot how many points of
damage you did see the other person but
you can't really see it if the camera is
in the way so
all right let's try that because it's
actually really cool I feel like in a
lot of modern games right now you always
get like hit markers who stopped to help
you confirm exactly when you get hit and
stuff like that but this is very very
much about your intuition revealing area
they have these are my way around all
around the stage that you can pick up
that add to your ultimate so they do
have a few ways for you to get your
ultimate without constantly
I don't even want to contest that
terrible terrible no bike planted hoho I
just wanted to see where he put it
oh it's down there okay you can shoot
through stuff also don't get too
comfortable trying to hide behind boxes
young player looks good welcome back
he's pre-concert without the personality
yeah he's very humble
I wasn't sure how wide it was gonna get
but one Academy was not touched up space
it's kind of interesting going back to a
shooter that doesn't cool they'll need
to patch the footsteps I mean they
really I think I really want you to rely
on strategizing with your team a little
less like running and gunning but I've
seen some pretty cool like squad wipes
in this game already
it's the other thing too is trying not
to be too passive because once you take
damage there is a character that see I I
always if I can one planted I tried to
run that's just the apex at me but this
game has to be confidence that I can
shoot someone and then defend myself
instead of trying to run because running
in that situation that's not gonna work
out last player standing even your
teammates those steps are pretty loud
too
got her good stuff Brandon says so many
cut pro circle yet this game already
which is interesting because I don't
feel like it's it's that much fun like
it's definitely more like CS there's
also no controller support deep the guy
right behind you just died
revealing area last player standing yeah
uh no stuff I know that especially in
shooters like this
the recoil you really have to hit that
let's be honest
I was having a little bit of issues
earlier the game kind of running into a
few glitches and not letting me actually
start get out of my way it's been pretty
good
revealing area thumbed them out of
charges oh yeah you can get hit by your
teammates ability I didn't OC so now
going under a fight in four shots to the
body two shots of the leg in comparison
to the other person killed me
which did 183 damage to me three shots
and two shots so I mean I the SMG it
makes sense they're using the assault
rifle
we are strong because we are together
don't forget that I'm broke I'm broke as
a joke all right there gun attachments
um as far as I got sober no and I'm also
not sure if you can unlock other weapons
but I do feel like I've died the weapons
I don't know they're dealing area
[Music]
probably not smart charges one enemy
remaining be the area
oh my god I heard her use that ability
last second and I was like wait she can
jump in the air she's pretty cool a
Stroud before the sequence and
everyone's throwing the the dome down
she could just kind of float over it hmm
I think it just shows I think the fact
that there's no controller is supported
just shows that they really want this to
be like a hard for you story like my way
has withstood the test of time dealing
area found them deplaned wrong
I miss the dirt well it's over here the
spike is over here revealing area there
they are I thought that was the other
one
switching sides Oh spike always switch
sides I was like I can't afford all
right I'm still in the process of trying
out all the guns too because so decent
selection to start with this is like an
auto pistol I think interesting AC
doesn't think there will be much casual
play yeah I think it's really tactical
you know it's gonna be hard to play this
gun cause really at least like not
without a team or without people to play
with I'd see me that was still on the
other side II was abandoned
I just takes up so much surface area
oh crap oh crap oh no player standing I
thought it was taking damage from that
cloud I don't know what the cloud does
actually need to read her abilities a
little bit more I landed I landed one
spot seconds left 478 damage but it
wasn't enough fear says I play key word
enough on console well you want to have
an issue playing distant I have not
tried any of it
ina curious but I'm told I don't know if
I'll ever be close enough let's check it
out where's everybody going
I didn't really like a shoot while I was
going down sing but they are standing I
mean I don't think it's your controller
because before halo was on PC recently
that was like a controller only yes
those were some of the best years right
there I'm kind of undecided on the recon
drone right now cuz it's not exactly
like Kryptos where if you just even have
someone in your line of sight it kind of
reveals them you do have to land you do
have to land being on the dart on the
person - they knew
Reyes yeah I kind of feel like you know
whatever you're comfortable with
whatever you like to use music it
doesn't matter if it's trawler if it's
keyboard if it's a piano I've seen some
interesting controllers in design as a
fighting game player I've seen plenty of
different types fight sticks out there
seeing people play fighting games on the
guitar hero controller poured it all on
piano keyboards on regular keywords also
so I thought man these cars they got it
on lock
I'm gonna fire into the abyss my be
remaining remember to fight the recoil
like the recoil the winds shifting our
favor wanna use last night hmm I kind of
like the banmal the most right now but I
need this shield
let me show you how to bust us get out
of my way revealing area
I feel like there's a lot away all of
you to be like in this some apex s
abilities got overwatch s capabilities
get the CS gunplay oh my god I am broke
one game is also very long anyone want
to get the spike oh yeah
I'm so glad they say something because
it's not the first time I've seen them
don't even leave the base without
getting the spike revealing area yeah
I'm not sure how effective sober really
is the special abilities like this I
have three health I shouldn't
who trained you I guess I'm gonna go one
enemy remaining
hmm and now we wait there soba is the
only one left somehow live for three
he'll um Akash you can heal if you have
a healer on your team there's a kid can
I switch heroes in the middle of game
using this finger right now I'll find
them I'm not sure if you can switch your
champion right in the middle of game
maybe on rounds Eddie found them shed an
eight or something
I could see the reticle off by a second
there's a barrel on the other side of
that box you can jump on it last player
standing she destroyed all of us she is
tearing it up
unimportant 30 seconds left
pretty good pretty good
I would like to buy to what is happening
reload it still broke as a joke yeah
they showed off the PS 5 controller
today you guys
revealing area get out of my way one
enemy remaining my lips enemies close
eyes up
[Music]
Stacy feeling Eddie jokes over
you're like I can never get through
poison you are teammate with the heart
here
they are having are they having good
sales for the ps4 right now that they've
announced some of the PS 5 stuff like at
this time I'll just wait for the PS 5 be
the area it's always it's always mild
what you're still learning a map here
like oops there's like Australia's open
door there
look why do i why do I reload so much
all right well you know we weren't
totally useless around more comfort for
those asked me in the chat this is a
closed beta right now so not everyone
has access to the beta but hopefully
this means they'll be ready to launch
Steven because it's gonna be really fun
to see how this game develops what
eSports want to look like you know this
is you know our one right now for me I'm
having fun we somehow are still in this
game follow the team
I will break the balance deploying drone
ding one headshot at 150
but there was another guy there we were
doing so well with the match point I
might have forgot the base you
you know what to do
we're so split up it's not what we need
right now we were all sticking together
pretty well at first I'm gonna go over
here this time I'm carrying us got it
note it I need to learn a team revealing
area
take flight
start again the aiming on that start is
so weird
it kind of cooks to right or left
beginning guy's brains rounder ideas
like why not oh yeah let's relocate them
30 seconds left
is gonna guess right and get me
recipes
defenders win all right close one but I
guess you know a lot of my team is
people just blocking pathways especially
on defense which is good let's go again
okay see one match was like 45 minutes
cuz it went really really far down in in
rounds
yeah it would seem so fun so far it is
pretty fun I just need to get my get my
aim up you know
then it'll be even more fun heck yeah
Brandon the new apex event looks so sick
actually that young blood hound skin I
really want that alright let's try
someone else
let's try stage she's the healer she's
got a mercy like ability where she can
kind of bring you back from the dead
I've only gotten resurrected like twice
and both times the second I was
resurrected I died so let's see if I can
help out the squad revive some people
and get this wo right um I don't know if
this game will be free but I mean I it
wouldn't be surprising cuz no League is
pretty pungent fruit Tara can throw the
whole play but it's free I've seen it
all before we'll see
I need to like slow walk more but the
shift key on this keyboard is buns so
I'm just kind of crouching a lot instead
I remember this nap I forgot I'm not
what's his face ah I don't know what
these abilities do I think it's like a
healing orbit
headshot okay
I was definitely just spamming cuz I
couldn't see it but we take those if
anybody hurting you at least I didn't
try to run that time oh hey thanks
Miguel free-to-play is always good it's
always been I agree with all right so
full healing we're all right slow orb
and then a barrier orb
okay we want that I did not buy weapons
you can sell your guns back but you
can't so a can nice oh no I took too
long oh yeah that's what I get that's
what I get
well let me not miss my average goodbye
there could only be one Phoenix I'm
comfy we're just gonna live with our
feet and get the light shields cuz I
want to try this wall ah I see
okay
isolate them and kill them
all right I'm gonna try something you're
trying to put this down over there oh
it's the ice wall I thought it was the
green one
I think that's another graph that tells
you where you land shot it's funny but
it's also like exposes you it's like
yeah this is where you really crap at
one perfect headshot for 200 - damage
holy smokes
can I heal myself all right so she has
the last layer CMG three on one we can
you find a fatal heart sorry second
russian see that's the other interesting
thing because these surveys do have
things like this like flash bang pretty
much which is really good but if you
throw it too far you don't have that
much time to rush and capitalize so you
got to make sure you throw it like
really close with somebody else like you
got a jet or something who can dash in
there for you
DOMA dude all right we're gonna try out
the slow orbit now see what that one's
about
no one went that way last time
ah
[Music]
okay okay I shouldn't try to confess
that player standing up - in there
I'm saving oh and you can tell your
teammates you know we should save stuff
we should trade stuff uh-huh I guess I
can't afford this goes around
I'm the inhale all right so
[Music]
jokes over good day
are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you could die to it even if it's Iran
seems bomb trust fate if you want to
know ways to die I got you I know
exactly in this game
alright so that went well get two more
of those ready we ready squad
this is a closed beta right qadi
Bob you know oh I can slow myself I
didn't know that get out of my way
one enemy remaining cannibal of oh they
got snakes okay we have arranged thank
goodness
makes them big all right we definitely
want somewhere these things spectres
been working out for us so far so let's
let's try to keep that going I have my
revine now actually that last round but
situation I put it down wrong again
my teammate Oh My lordy oh I didn't
realize
[Applause]
[Music]
oh did they plant the spike no what
happened whatever they did I wasn't
paying attention
oh we didn't come on Spike I got you got
it um guys almost forgot my key
yeah my two Street great this guy
definitely knows problem player standing
they were not still over there actually
yeah they do give you information on how
much damage each gun does also and like
the water penetration so you see like
the assault rifles have like medium wall
penetration and got like the heavy
weapons I haven't really tried on the
heavy weapons yeah
okay they're not better than me
she fellas their way I mean they might
be
where's fight
did we not pick it up are we bad one
enemy remaining jokes over player
standing fire super high level to
remember all right my gosh money let me
spin all right seven and six we're doing
significantly better than last game
somehow so scratch is interesting I kind
of feel like my heels are healthy but
you know you can't I pity sizes
[Music]
no charges 78 two shots to the chest
Oh what gun is she using curious that
wasn't too bad though it is three on one
low
what kind of left our teammate oops
gosh I know right rip and tear now this
is like almost the opposite of that doom
is like never stop moving and in this
game in the tutorial they're literally
like stop before you shoot so as much as
the like Halo and apex player in me
wants to just keep strafing until the
end of time just two more just two more
cribs let's go you got this you hear him
you hear those those dirty feet those
dirty grubby feet
it'd be like that if you like that
sometimes you know just saying oh I
thought we I thought it was gonna be
like just about to blow up I do I just
don't allowed it thank you
anyone need anything how do i buy this
for other people I know you can find it
so know how to yet yeah what's up I'm
sure welcome to the stream we're out
here learning some valoran
get out of my way no one who run all
right now he's getting the hang of it
jokes over
[Music]
all right Chris found in the half we
cannot keep our goods
after this spend all well is that gun he
was using I want to use that good I
don't see it I think you can somehow
unlock other guns I'm not a hundred
percent sure
I see it better at like my mouse work
right now too
I tried to hardly just like move my
mouse all the way in one direction I
don't really have the space for them
anyway how long do I have
can I there we go all right
probably 30 seconds left all the way
around so far around fire up there 10
seconds left
we never picked up the spike what
happened guys why oh my goodness I don't
remember hearing the cutest one enemy
remaining buddy gets the spike switching
sides okay well there goes our cribs
though look at cribs at the top of the
leaderboard that's the first time I've
inflicted fall damage on myself raise my
mouse sensitivity oh I don't know if
that'll be a good idea here you see how
bad my aim is already player standing um
oh man they done rushed us down I get a
whopping 16 damage this place is nice
let's take it nice
hmm I'd like this character would be a
little more useful if I kill myself also
but still pretty good I can bring her a
[ __ ] gun
she's like a healer I'm not healing
because he's left to get some kills to
get the old off they still do have to do
something or capture orbs capture ropes
to coerce someone came through that door
and left bike planted last player
standing Ripper erroneous um you can
medias with most of the weapons you
can't 80s with like the pistols I had to
use the shotgun much so I don't know if
he to 80s or maybe it's just a few
pistols
so he was doing a little bit of strafing
there too which you just have to stop
drop together and shuttle bury the dead
transgressions uh all right
can't even afford anything good right
now where are we going
yeah let's stick with cribs Christmas is
still it's like your teammates so spike
planted
that scared me
taken down I tried to heal them quick oh
my goodness somebody call the cops
blade murder all right decisions
decision go we can push them but
everybody else
I just see his lifeless body over there
bagel clunky feet spike planted oh wait
that works oh I can heal myself eh all
right you learn something new every
round player standing why did I go for
silly crotch shots match alright so you
can heal yourself
oops so that's good that's good news now
that I know what to do that I was like
it has to be
sorry alright let's go let's go I tried
to spray and pray and see what fit would
break out of it jokes over
spike planted
Oh attackers wings did you see that stat
it's a that I did over a thousand damage
and the other person did a thousand oh I
think that was the bomb yeah yeah a
thousand damage that'll get you all
right that was fun even though we got
bodied I feel like getting more used to
it I need to beat switch here right I
gotta be like Oh with the instincts like
everywhere I even see movement
that's not my team it's like I might as
well at least try to go for it right
does this stream have drops I don't
think so last I checked I think it was
just twitch streams that were doing it
but thank you for stopping by anyways
you cannot run there are some characters
that have like jet which I haven't even
had a chance to play yet because every
time I try to go pick her everyone
someone else has her every time and she
has like a dash B she can go hide from
the air or she can dash forward which is
really good it's kind of dingy like if
you play overwatch um let's see who else
can we try let's try this guy I haven't
tried them yet but because I've seen a
lot of people use him he's got that
little flashbang that my teammate was
hitting me with a lot earlier so let me
try not to hit my teammates
I am having fun playing this game like I
know it's not the best gameplay but
I'm definitely not the type of player
where I could pick up a game in day one
be super good I'm the type of player
that I need to sit down and take my time
and figure things out like it takes me a
little bit longer to get good at
something than the average person but
you know everyone's different some oh I
want to try this bad boy and that's okay
so Q is my flash bang I got my little
flame wall
guess I'll throw that over there wait
yeah
oh okay okay I wasn't exactly sure how
that ax oh I can heal in this this snap
has cool stuff too you can like go
through here open this door
like flank
nice one thing I would change about this
game um how much I mean I don't have
anything yet that I would change because
this is literally like my fourth or
fifth game I played so far so I think
it's a little too early to make any hard
decisions on things I should change or
not because I'm just super early into it
I think it's really cool though that
everyone's pretty unique with their
abilities they may have similar things
like walls and stuff but they all act
differently and do different things okay
oh so I pick which way it goes oh no
wonder no wonder my teammate kept
hitting me with that okay
[Music]
that Raven last that's not their actual
day they got the purple hoodie on okay
okay we did something that time let's
get these idiots the math layout looks
very familiar
I I don't know if I put this one on the
stream earlier I might have need the
shield needs them together all right so
this guy's pretty fun I still need to
figure out this cute so I think I can
choose to curve it left or curve it
frame so let's try it I clipped the
corner the wall up so sorry dude I said
I would try it now that making glasses
now we have also enemy spy
I shouldn't have pushed that far forward
I knew there was more than one person
they're all one enemy remaining cool the
pop off from the characters though it's
pretty good alright that was fun
alright so it seems like the party is
definitely
one enemy remaining bakery last player
standing
thirty seconds left
[Music]
holy moly
the one on one it always gets your heart
racing
I like playing search-and-destroy in cod
so like I do like this format a lot
my aim is just not very good on PCs so
it's all good we gotta keep it moving I
definitely felt more confident that I
have that wall there and it does some
healing I think of the three champions
I've tried so far which was sage soba
and this homie right here I don't know
his name
I was gonna take damage alright
super far I'm sorry my bad my bad I'm
just not going to use that when I'm
around teaming it's going off their
clothes but I didn't realize that
orab associate
spike planted I saw the bullet recoil
light going kind of try to pull the gun
down or just burst fire more hey alright
we're gonna get this one done so far all
right I gotta get better with this Q
it's really good I just they're not
gonna get
[Laughter]
no it's it's really hard to use that
thing the curve is so short you think he
can make it over wall he knew what was
there he hurts the dachshund screen down
yeah so if you look at the mini-map you
can kind of see where these doors where
are these runners taking you so like one
of them takes you all the way around to
the other side and then one just takes
you kind of cuts you through because
you'd like the green lines James says
this gave any good it is pretty good
like it's fun it's fun it's a little
chaotic I need to use my little all
right I don't know what my old does it
oh it's like it's like it's the death
totem all right
we're death totem in this round let's do
it
thank you so you guys seven for
reminding me
I'm just so mind boggled by trying to
get his cue to actually like land
somewhere nice
but where am i I'm gonna waste my whole
that's pretty cool so that was fun you
see like sometimes you can't actually
kill people clean right in the ear Oh
Carmen Carmen you want revenge
now's your chance oh no I'm broke again
first I'll change the system G for a bit
my gut tells me this will be free like
the other riot games but you never know
until it launches you know they say what
they sign it but I think this will take
off and get a share of the popular
shooter market I mean to be honest I
think it will I think about because
there's a lot of people who are still
super diehard csgo fans you know so help
go it up no I hit him a few times but
not enough I'm not very good with smg's
okay
I'm very passive when it comes to a shoe
tree like this so I'm not confident in
my ability to write to 1/3
let's see where everyone else is they're
pretty spread out
it looks like jet is making their way to
our other teammate we've got two people
at be anyways fun
Oh nail spa 30 seconds left nice
headshot always nice blocking off the
pathway just need to be mindful if
someone's at a maybe trying to plant the
spike over there trying to see if I hear
anybody remaining
[Music]
[Music]
I'm glad I switched the camera real
quick
going up
I was like can you see me are you just
making the right reads right now my
house much is ready o our jet done sorry
- on - you guys got this spike planted
oops they planted at a this time hey
it's got me just that shook is just for
all the different reasons
message sent it sucks when you're trying
to do your ability and then they shoot
you and you're like summoning it alright
let's try again
ooh I'm broke I'm broke I play with fire
right now haha get it get it
alright we out
okay you know honestly it's better that
the queue is not as easy to land because
if it was I already told you guys I
don't like that
SMG versus a our long-range battles oh
yeah like even the chart on the right
combat report two shots that a yard too
much chest a tit fourteen and three it's
pretty good who's my favorite hero so
far and come on Flynn reload my channel
remaining checking out some valoran
everybody's melons gettin pop today
someone has a salt shaker emote I saw
earlier it was pretty great ah chills
who's my favorite hero so far sorry I
got distracted by the immaculate gunplay
from Eric here I would probably say this
champion that I'm using I think his name
is Phoenix seconds beat
[Music]
therefore now everybody's got
I'm so sorry
you're probably like yo what's next I'm
definitely getting good water and
remaining and really around Houston all
right they must be over itby I saw my
little - I'll save it for next game last
round before the switch halftime don't
save a thing it's halftime okay I need
to work on my anger such an angry person
ever
agir now I just angry with myself when I
make like the stains on mistake over and
over and over again but I'm not actually
mad it's a more disappointed in myself
around too bad there was no one there
for it however slowly but surely
oh dang oh dang yeah so those stories
are one-way door so like you can come in
she can't go out
I see the spike no one to run 30 seconds
left go it up cool down
ten seconds left last player standing
one enemy remaining so let us fight it
out like that so funny
he grabbed the spike let's follow that
guy he's got it how crazy it gets any
harder now watch me play fighting games
one good time see some real stuff she's
really fun watch me play against level
three xfactor vergil you'll see some
salt guarantee it
let's keep it rolling she reminds me of
a leader battle angel a little bit
pretty eyes impressed
oh she's impressed by you guys those I
think that is a compliment
yeah the world may never know
Oh what's up rad what's up Mario
Akash don't burst my bubble she was
impressed by me all right she she looked
past the face of my character and
directly at me the player I know it for
a fact
oh no rivers gonna I don't like hanging
out in that spot anyways though because
that teleporter room is right there and
flanked so easily oh you ain't coming
back last player standing 30 seconds
left
enemy remain you're out no I'm the only
one oh no oh no ten seconds left
I thought I'd have time I should've just
stopped trying to plant it and sorry
chase again it does have a sound effect
it does have a sound effects on my mom
continued to overwhelm them everyone in
over here so that's where we're going
oh no whenever a teammate says hurry and
already
I'm not gonna use flash
[Music]
you're standing but you know I'll pop
them real quick get a little bit extra
money my impressions on this game so far
is that I am having fun although it's
like taking me a little while to just
get used to the gunplay okay so the gun
plan what not obviously because it's a
it's much more tactical than the type of
shooters I'm used to and it's been a
really really long time since I played
CS so I like it so far I think it's cool
I'd like each game I get a little bit
better you know my fan gets a little bit
better but the abilities of stuff is
what really makes it interesting
careful dough because they're very
useful like justice dome here like
ruining the line of sight makes the map
different you can't bet on it being the
same every time can't bet on each joke
look at a decent amount of health back
oh my goodness I had a doorway right
behind me I'm like camp in there one
enemy remaining
try to back out of last player standing
oh okay I made it yeah thousand fourteen
damage match point
what's Daniel Hamm I'm like having the
wall so I can get some heels
so I I could be wrong but I see these
two little icons above my II and I'm
wondering if I have to get two head
shots to get my no I don't know why I
thought he was gonna like walk right oh
I thought the he that's my English just
Crouch strafing me to onboard they're
pretty far away from each other I even
used this character yet I don't know
what I think one of my favorite 30
seconds left
they're mad Merriman rate is almost ours
take it hmm I'm broke again
yeah so no shields broke
that's how broke we are today anyone
know the minimum specs that's a good
question I do not know I mean I don't
feel like this would be super intensive
on your computer but you never know
[Music]
two of them that time I looks
yeah those teleporter rooms they're
pretty good friggin good show Oh y-yeah
oh my oldest backup still got it
I definitely use my old one - if I was
gonna do that like two rounds ago and I
forgot these
I want to see you like whoever I'm
watching I want to see like more details
can't really scroll like through this
HUD or anything I guess I just already
11 in you to read up but I think I had
this character unlocked
there's a few characters I don't have
unlocked yet is this a second version of
overwatch um definitely not in terms of
the gun Cory but ability wise it's kind
of like got this much 10 second a lesson
because you're all three abilities
yeah he was not gonna certify that
that's for sure
alright guys come on we started off
strong I literally think we're on like
desperate match point or something
they're desperate crap
[Music]
I'm somehow still positive even though I
died 12 times Eric is still carrying us
[Applause]
[Applause]
and I still don't have enough to buy the
full rifle I'm struggling with these
estimates right now yes I do
I don't even know how I can get credits
oh wait hold on I need a drop please you
know I can it's fine I think this is no
run
[Music]
that's the so vault
last player standing
finally I have a lot of fun with this
game obviously I still need to practice
up oh I can recruit a new agent this guy
here is where I can see some info I'm
getting all the rewards they're like
good stuff you finally won controllers
are experts in slicing of dangerous
territory to set their team up for
success okay
equipment and senior eager need a
launcher nice sky smoke right and we see
that all the time and he must be the one
with the yeah the orbital strike alright
I'll recruit this oh wait already on him
JK she looks so cool
showstopper fire shoots a rocket that
does massive area damage on contact
with anything that sounds like I'm going
to blow myself up an accident from the
shadows this guy looks really cool it's
like Reaper and Raven mix together I'll
recruit him cuz he looks really cool yes
oh gosh sweet sweet victory but yeah
guys that is actually gonna be it for
today thank you guys so much for tuning
in I had a lot of fun I hope that you
did too this is literally like day one
officially been playing this for like
two to three hours but I'm having a
blast so far I feel like every game gets
a little bit more interesting and it
gets a little bit more easy to play but
still tough I'm excited to see where
this game goes in terms of eSports I
want to see more tournaments which
rivals event that they had recently I
was really really cool and you know
getting to see it at high level just
motivates me more and to get better and
it's all a grind and I'm here for it so
I'm excited to see more I wanna see
where this game goes and whenever you
guys get a chance to play it I
definitely want to hear what you guys
think too so thank you so much for
tuning in thank you guys for being
awesome and like always stay safe out
there we love you guys and we love your
support and you can catch us every
weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific time for some
a GameSpot live action so thank you guys
so much I will catch you on the flipside
have a good one